i love how uh like during the
conversation earlier about whatever the
[ __ ] it was just i i was trying to
listen to what you were saying but just
from the outside i could just hear like
a shitload of cicadas
cicadas yeah cicadas cicadas cicada
am i the weird one i say
cicada okay google how do you pronounce
cicadas
sorry to anyone who is [ __ ] uh
probably just like we got two with
does that say american or uk what is
that what's going on
oh american is cicada oh i say cicadas
oh yeah okay this is america wait wait
i'm correct british chicago british says
is one of those words i've only ever
been here heard
americans say yeah because we don't have
it in the uk no one says it in the uk
i've never heard that british person
literally sounds like something out of
harry potter no it's cicada
where we had to talk about like summer
anime things i put sakai
i i i thought cicada or cicada was spelt
c-i-r-c-a-d yeah he literally wrote sir
carter
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah i thought cicada had a r in it this
entire time and apparently it doesn't
um it's cicada now yeah but yeah i mean
i've said this before they never fix you
but i remember when i first moved japan
and i literally had gone my entire life
thinking that every cicada sound effect
in every anime was just a stock sound
effect right because they all sound
exactly the same you watch like one
summer anime episode and you're like
they're just using the same [ __ ]
sound effect as the other anime right
and i didn't realize until i moved to
japan that
cicadas just all sound exactly the
[ __ ] same yeah i thought it was just
a [ __ ] audio jungle stock sound
effects no
i don't know how they sound so similar
it's literally just been hardwired into
their brain to be like
sound like this at this exact interval
yeah to the point where i was like
sitting at home one night um or one day
and i literally thought i had the tv on
playing a random anime and i didn't
realize that just the window was open
yeah i literally like went to my living
room to turn off the tv because i was
like i'm not no one's watching anything
and
lo and behold it was just the window and
i couldn't tell the difference between a
tv stock sound effect and the real life
yeah
man
have you seen them flying yeah they're
[ __ ] massive they're terrifying yeah
i was outside uh the trash taste office
and uh i was walking listening to music
just jamming you know and one flew in my
[ __ ] face and i [ __ ] smacked it
i smacked it and i felt really bad hit
the woman in front of me on her on her
back
you literally just tossed this
yeah and she turned around and i was
like
[ __ ] [ __ ] playing ping pong
because i just hit it because i panicked
it's [ __ ] smelly no what's what's
scarier is when they land on your
balcony but like like they don't say
that but you think they're dead they
just don't move yeah they just like kind
of pop and just flop down you're like oh
is he dead and then you touch it it's
like
yeah there's one outside my door so i
opened the door yeah and then
what is that
scarier than any horror film because i
just opened my door you don't expect
them
that's [ __ ] up
i'm gonna use the last of last of my
life to troll this huge it was literally
like under the door so i opened the door
and it was just it got like
the door like like rubbed it or
something and you're like
ah what else what is that
i've never seen one before either i've
never seen one this is my first time i
had never seen one before either so i
had no idea what they look like and
these [ __ ] [ __ ] are so big yeah
the [ __ ] master's [ __ ] youtube
back in my like apartment yeah they're
terrible also another thing i didn't
know is that like i i had always assumed
like i remember the first time i came to
japan like these [ __ ] are loud
like yeah like like you you need to wear
you need like noise casting headphones
to like even survive outside what do you
think it's like a swarm of them yeah
i thought i walked past this tree and
i'm like man these there are like a
swarm of cicadas just in this tree and
then it's like it just like suddenly
just stops and i'm like what's going on
and then i realized it's one
[ __ ] making all this sound yeah
one [ __ ] makes so it's so loud
and it's actually like impressive how
[ __ ] loud this cicada is yeah right
because i
i'm on my balcony and like i can hear
what i think is a swarm of cicadas on
like the other side of the city or
something and then i realized just one
because it just like it's so weird like
having like a like it's so weird going
outside and just hearing like a [ __ ]
noise like it sounds like an alarm yeah
it just suddenly stops as well and then
just suddenly stops
why why do they make noise what are they
trying is this on a mate or something
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] say why are they i think they're
like don't they like rub their legs
together to make that sound or something
i think it's like a violin yeah like
like the world's shittiest violin
yeah because apparently they can only
mate during like a very short period of
their life
um during the summer yeah during the
summer so they're like
they're [ __ ] horny as [ __ ] man they
need to [ __ ] they're the lads of the
insects yeah yeah and then they [ __ ]
once and they die and then that's it but
that's just their entire life they they
live for that one [ __ ] and then they die
[Laughter]
honestly i can think of worse ways to
die yeah
than having like a not so amazing that
you're like all right life is peaked now
some people die from cows yeah that's
like